Death is something we all deal with in our lives
Whether it is a family member, a pet, or your last end. In fact. About one hundred people
They die every minute in the world. But what happens when you die?
In the first moments after death, the last breath of oxygen in your body is depleted
And the activity of your brain stops. While the neurons stop working. Your brain stops
Hormone secretion that regulates the functions of the body. During this time some body functions may remain functioning
For a few seconds, because of the use of the ATP power reserve - which is the primary power source
In your body - the muscles relax including the sphincter muscles, which means the possibility of urination
Or defecation "Akramkm God".
About 15-25 minutes after death the lack of blood flow across the capillaries leads to
The pallor of death that he sees on the skin of the dead. And because the heart no longer works
There is no blood drive through your body causing gravity to pull
Blood in the lower part of the body.
After several hours of blood withdrawal, the color of the skin changes to red on the Benghazi
Skin color changes up to 12 hours. This is one of the ways that
Investigators have obtained forensic evidence and forensic doctors to determine the time of death and the location of the body
dead.
Within 3-6 hours the phenomenon of dead stiffness occurs, "gnawing", your body will not only lose its energy sources
But the cells of the degraded organs will also leak calcium into the muscle cells, which in turn
Will bind to the proteins that are responsible for muscle contraction. Causing
Involuntary tension and muscle stiffness, which in any case lasts for a duration of
Ranging from 24-48 hours.
Until this moment, unless your body is chemically mummified or saved in some way, the
Your body will slowly start to rot as well. Without adequate blood flow
Dead cells accumulate with carbon dioxide and cause acidity.
All of this weakens the cell membrane and eventually makes it explode and release its cellular nerve
Which contain activated protein and enzymes that further work to break down surrounding tissues.
There are also about 100 trillion bacteria that thrive on your body.
Bacteriological bacteria in the gastrointestinal tract begin to eat underground organs (inside the abdominal cavity). This process
Known as the process of decay or rot, a situation where things become foul smell. The breakdown of amino acids
By bacteria produces a very lukewarm gas, which attracts certain insects such as licorice
And the big blue flies that lay their eggs in rotting tissues. Eggs hatch during day,
The larvae or ring tones eat tissues to survive their lives until they become full-grown.
After several weeks, these tones (larvae) can consume 60% of the tissues of the body causing the drilling
Which allow rotting liquids and gases to escape. Between 20-50 days begins fermentation fermentation
By attacking the larvae of the beetle, protozoa and fungi. This process is known as dry tooth decay, and can last for a year,
But they occur faster in high temperatures.
Over the years, plants and animals eat the remains of body parts, including
Remains of bone. In the end, if you leave these elements completely to each piece of the body
It will break and its basic molecules will be recycled.
If you want to learn more about the psychological side of death, check out our AsapTHOUGHT toolkit
Most likely 5 people are remorse before death. It's amazing to see what people think about their last moments.
Link in description.
I do subscribe!